und jetzt das heute journal
mit gundula gause und claus kleber guten
abend die quintessenz dieses wahltages
die traditionsparteien boten arg gerupft
in brandenburg und sachsen sind aber
noch einmal davon gekommen sie können
weiter regierungen führen die spd in
brandenburg die cdu in sachsen aber
beide müssen mehr verbündete zu sich ins
boot holen
die zahlen hat matthias fornoff im
großen und im detail matthias beginnen
wir doch bitte in sachsen ja guten abend
aus dresden es wird noch ausgezählt in
sachsen aber es gibt eine frische
hochrechnung und die schauen wir uns
direkt an die cdu käme demnach auf 32,2
prozent die linke auf 10,3 die spd 7,7
die afg 27,7 die reihenfolge der
parteien in dieser grafik übrigens
richtet sich nach dem ergebnis der
letzten landtagswahl die grünen 8,5
prozent die fdp 4,5 prozent nicht drin
die freien wähler mit 3,3 prozent
genauso wenig wie wir sehen wenn wir
nach unten schauen viele parteien die
deutlich verloren haben die cdu die
linke die spd und eine partei die sehr
deutlich gewinnt das ist die afg und wir
schauen jetzt auf die sitzverteilung im
landtag von dresden
die cdu kommt auf 45 sitze die linke auf
die spd auf 10 und die afg auf 39 da
gibt es eine spezialität eine
besonderheit denn es gibt nur 30
kandidaten auf der liste
die zugelassen wurden aber die afd wird
einige von diesen neuen noch mit
direktkandidaten dazugewinnen
wir kommen auf zu den grünen die auf
zwölf sitze kommen und wir schauen uns
an was das heißt zur bildung einer
regierung hier in sachsen
cdu und spd kommen auf 55 sitze das
reicht deutlich nicht wenn die grünen
noch mit im boot sind dann kommen wir
auf 67 das reicht deutlich wir sehen
hier die absolute mehrheit bei 61 und
cdu und grüne schwarz grün verfehlt die
mehrheit ebenfalls cdu mit afd ist immer
klar ausgeschlossen worden schon im
vorfeld erhöhte wahlbeteiligung haben
wir in sachsen noch stärker als in
brandenburg und da schauen wir jetzt auf
das ergebnis die hochrechnung für
brandenburg spd 26,2 cdu 15,6 linke 10,7
afd 23,5 prozent mehr als verdoppelt
gegenüber vor fünf jahren
die grünen legen zu auf 10,8 prozent bvb
freie wähler 5 prozent ist damit im
landtag selbst wenn es noch drunter geht
sie haben mindestens ein direktmandat
gewonnen
die fdp 4,1 prozent nicht im landtag
vertreten
was heißt das für zur bildung einer
regierung in potsdam spd und linke die
haben bisher hier regiert die kommen auf
35 sitze 45 braucht man für die absolute
mehrheit spd linke und grüne kommen
exakt auf diesen wert 45 das ist also
ganz ganz knapp und spd cdu und grüne
diese regierungskonstellation hätte 50
sitze und würde damit klar eine absolute
mehrheit haben
zur analyse matthias kommen wir gleich
noch jetzt schauen wir erstmal auf die
ereignisse des tages und wir sprechen
auch mit entscheidenden personen sowohl
auf den beiden landesebene als auch auf
der bundesebene das haben wir uns
vorgenommen
also gehen wir zunächst mal zum alltag
und dem wahlabend in sachsen hand in
hand mit seiner lebensgefährtin kam
michael kretschmer kurz nach der ersten
hochrechnung zu seiner partei ließ sich
feiern und bejubeln mit dem ergebnis ist
der amtierende ministerpräsident
zufrieden
zwar war die cdu bei einer landtagswahl
noch nie so schwach wie heute aber
immerhin stärkste partei das war nicht
selbstverständlich eine stabile
regierung zu geben
[Musik]
falls behandlung geben morgen gehen aber
wichtigste ist getan meine klare das was
bei der spd eine wahlparty werden sollte
glich eher einem trauerspiel keine
reaktionen versteinerte mienen als das
bisher schlechteste wahlergebnis in der
geschichte der sächsischen spd überhaupt
genannt wurde trotzdem optimismus beim
spitzenkandidaten
ja man braucht traurig sein ja man darf
sich ärgern ja man doch vieles als
ungerecht empfinden aber denk dran
es geht nicht nur um den ersten
september sondern es geht auch um den
zweiten september wie geht es dann in
diesem land weiter und das ist genau
auch die burg gute botschaft des
heutigen tages es wird eine gute
regierung geben wir haben stabile
verhältnisse es gibt klare antwort
regelrecht dort bei der afg brach heute
abend wohl der größte jubel aus mit
berliner unterstützung wurde gefeiert
und auf das rekordergebnis angestoßen
die afg sieht sich als den eigentlichen
wahlsieger und will eine bärenstarke
opposition in sachsen geben so urban
heute ist ein historischer tag unsere
junge partei uns gibt es erst seit sechs
jahren hat die cdu-hochburg sachsen
gehörig ins wanken gebracht wir haben
die höchsten zuwächse von allen parteien
die afd ist heute abend der wahlsieger
schockstarre dagegen bei den linken
mit einem solch schlechten ergebnis
hatten sie nicht gerechnet
verluste waren absehbar aber nicht in
diesen dimensionen
ich meine diese dramatische ergebnis das
wir heute eingefahren als eine
katastrophe ist aber wahrscheinlich hat
es vor allen dingen damit etwas zu tun
dass wir zum schluss ein duell hatten
nämlich die frage zu beantworten liegt
die afg oder liegt die cdu vorne und da
sind wir unter die räder gekommen auf
die richtigen themen haben wohl die
grünen gesetzt jubeln über ihr ergebnis
das aber trotzdem unter deren
erwartungen
aber sie könnten die königsmacher in
einer neuen regierung werden und macht
gleich klar wir haben gesagt wir wollen
verantwortung übernehmen was aber auch
ganz klar ist es kann kein weiter so
geben mit cdu und spd und wir grünen
dann als anhängsel die ein bisschen
umweltpolitik machen sondern es muss ich
ganz klar was ändern
eine regierungsbeteiligung hätte sich
auch die fdp vorstellen können
durch diese traum ist ausgeträumt die
liberalen werden weitere fünf jahre
nicht im sächsischen landtag vertreten
sein
alles sieht nun nach einer schwarz rot
grünen koalition aus ein neues
farbenspiel für sachsen
guten abend herr kretschmer guten abend
sie sind noch einmal davon gekommen die
niederlage ist nicht gekommen die zum
teil drohte aber nach wie vor ist es das
schlechteste landtagswahlergebnis das
sie je hatten und sie werden sich auf
mindestens einen koalitionspartner mehr
einstellen müssen mit dem sie
kompromisse machen
trotzdem verstehe ich ihre äußerungen
heute so als ob sie mehr den stil als
die substanz ihrer regierungsarbeit
ändern wollen na ja wir haben jetzt in
den vergangenen 20 monaten diesem land
einen neuen schwung gegeben wir haben
auch es geschafft neues vertrauen zu
generieren aber wir sind nicht am ende
und das mussten nächsten fünf jahre
genauso weitergehen das muss für die
menschen auch anfassbarer werden was wir
tun aber die chance haben willst sie
werden wahrscheinlich zwei
koalitionspartner brauchen welchem
präferieren sie im moment das kann ich
ihnen noch nicht sagen dass wir das
wahlergebnis zeigen ich bin demokrat ich
akzeptiere dieses wahlergebnis und bin
bereit wenn es dem land dient eine gute
positive regierung zu bilden
könnten sie sich auch vorstellen mit
einem mit dem mandat von heute eine
minderheitsregierung zu führen die dann
je nach dem was sie braucht sich bei
grünen oder spd oder notfalls auch mal
bei der afd
die mehrheit für sinnvolle maßnahmen
holt ich halte davon gar nichts ist
glaube ich mehr eine idee aus einem
politischen seminar als aus der praxis
es muss uns gelingen uns
zusammenzusetzen als demokraten und so
lange miteinander zu reden und
uns zu überzeugen dass wir einen
vernünftigen plan für fünf jahre
regierung haben die alternative ist das
freie spiel der kräfte daran ist nichts
besser
es führt meistens zum chaos und zu
unsicherheiten und dieser freistaat
sachsen braucht eine stabile regierung
damit er diese vielen zukunftsaufgaben
die vor uns liegen auch bewältigen
könnten wenn jeder sechste sachse oder
16 heute die afg wählt wie lang kann man
dann wirklich noch eine politik
durchhalten wie sie gesagt mit denen
rede ich noch nicht mal ich lasse mich
von ihnen noch nicht mal unterstützen
das ist für mich kein kontakt fähiger
partner selbstverständlich reden wir
miteinander das ist ja auch wieder eine
dieser mythen die die afg über sich
selbst verbreitet in jeder
landtagsdebatte in jeder
ausschusssitzung wird über die
politischen vorstellungen gesprochen und
gerungen und abgewägt was richtig und
was falsch ist
aber es gibt eben keine koalition und es
gibt auch keine duldung weil diese
partei in der tat immer mehr in richtung
rechtsextremismus abweicht die letzten
48 42 stunden dieses wahlkampfs waren
wieder ein beispiel dafür
und das mache ich nicht ich möchte dass
wir eine vernünftige regierung für
dieses land bilden und keine populisten
und spalte
danke für das gespräch herr kretschmer
und einen schönen abend
bitte das gespräch haben wir vor einer
stunde etwa geführt den sachsen ging es
um die zukunft einer fast 30 jahre von
der cdu geführten regierung in
brandenburg dann das gegenbild drei
jahrzehnte spd ob sie darf weitermachen
muss sich aber auch eine neue mehrheit
im parlament zusammenbauen nach diesem
wahlabend
die erleichterung ist groß bei den
sozialdemokraten zwar sind die verluste
deutlich doch sie jubeln detroit gezeigt
der wieder ministerpräsident werden will
das land wird damit erneut von der spd
regiert wir werden möglichst schnell in
die sondierungsgespräche gehen um eine
regierung zu haben die eines vereint
erfolg für die menschen im land war
gewinner ist die fdp
ist sie nicht mehr hofft stärkste kraft
geworden hat aber ihren stimmenanteil
verdoppelt das haben auch berichte über
frühere kontakte ihres spitzenkandidaten
zu rechtsextremen nicht verhindert die
afd ist gekommen um zu bleiben es wird
keine politik möglich sei enttäuschung
bei der cdu noch im juli war sie in
umfragen mit der spd gleichauf doch nun
herbe verluste mitregieren wollen die
christdemokraten dennoch wir sind bereit
wird den partnern die in brandenburg mit
uns gespräche führen wollen dazu auch
gespräche zu führen um eine stabile
regierung in brandenburg hinzubekommen
die linke die linke hofft zwar dass es
nach zehn jahren koalition mit der spd
erneut reicht dieses mal mit den grünen
als dritten partner
doch die verluste sind schmerzhaft wenn
die wahlergebnisse noch hinter den
umfragen zurück bleiben oder diese erste
prognose hinter den umfragen zurück
bleibt dann ist es schon bitter
das ist eine deutliche schwächung für
die linke im nächsten landtag
wahlgewinner sind auch die grünen die
sich hoffnung machen können auf eine
mitarbeit in einem dreierbündnis mit der
spd wir sind zweistellig geworden wir
sind sehr glücklich wir haben im
vergleich zu 2014 erheblich dazugewonnen
und vor allen dingen wir haben eine
partei die wächst die enthusiastisch ist
sie was vor hatten was bewegen welt wird
spitzenkandidat peter wieder will den
zahlen kaum glauben die freien wähler
haben die fünf prozent hürde geschafft
und sind im neuen landtag
also letzten tage haben uns gezeigt dass
wir die richtigen inhalte gesetzt haben
viel zuspruch gab es in der bevölkerung
und wenn sich das ergebnis so bereitet
und so stabilisiert dann ist das ein
großer erfolg für freie wähler auf
bundespolitischer durchbruch für eine
politische kraft der mitte verlierer des
abends sind die freien demokraten sie
haben erneut den einzug in den landtag
verpasst wenn auch sehr knapp
sie haben es gewaltig gesteigert von
2014 das ist schön wenn es nicht
gereicht haben sollte ist extrem
ärgerlich vielleicht ist doch mal ab
reich folgen wir können heute wirklich
noch keine analyse abgeben
gesteigert hat sich auch die
wahlbeteiligung 60 prozent der
brandenburger gaben ihre stimme ab
guten abend nach potsdam herr beutel
schön genannter kleber sie haben sich
enorm reingehängt in den letzten wochen
sie haben große beliebtheitswerte die
große mehrheit ihrer bürger sagt sie
finden ihre wirtschaftliche lage gut und
trotzdem ist es ihnen nicht gelungen die
afg wirklich abzuschütteln warum nicht
ja das ist ein punkt der hat mit vielen
vielen fragen was zu tun also gerade
hier in ostdeutschland jetzt im
dreißigsten jahr des mauerfalls fühlen
sich viele menschen nicht gerecht
behandelt das geht beim lohn los es geht
bei der rente weiter es geht also um
soziale fragen das ist gibt andere
fragen infrastrukturausbau vieles dauert
zu lange auch dinge die angefasst werden
wenn man zwölf jahre braucht um ein
stückchen gleis zu bauen dann ist das
einfach zu lang also wir haben viel zu
tun in den kommenden jahren um dieses
vertrauen zurückzugewinnen
sie sprechen ein bisschen wie ein
vertreter der opposition aber es gab
eine ungebrochene verantwortung der spd
seit dem mauerfall verbrannten wollen ja
und ich glaube das hat man mir auch sehr
gut getan wir haben brandenburg heute
erfolgsgeschichte geschrieben man kann
durchaus sagen dass lang stand noch nie
so gut da wie es heute dasteht den
menschen ging es noch nie so gut und
diese erfolgsgeschichte weiter
fortzuschreiben das ist die große
herausforderung allerdings sind die
anforderungen der menschen auch andere
geworden sie wollen heute mehr das in
infrastruktur investiert wird sie wollen
dass bestimmte dinge in ihrem direkten
lebensumfeld schneller verbessert werden
also da kommen richtig große
herausforderung von zu auf die kommende
regierung in ihrem wahlkampf kurs haben
sie die ganz klare kante gegen die afg
gefahren das war zum schluss sogar ein
richtiger anti fdp wahlkampf der spd
nehmt uns unseren will ihn nicht weg
also eine ganz klare kante und
konfrontation andere auf der
konservativen seite sind da ein bisschen
vorsichtiger im ton
weil sie möglicherweise eigene
konservative wähler nicht verschrecken
wollen haben sie empfehlungen für die
kollegen
also ich glaube dass wir diese
auseinandersetzung offensiv führen
müssen und dass wir auch immer wieder
darauf hinweisen müssen dass dieses land
vor allem eines braucht trifft
deutschland in gänze aber es betrifft
natürlich auch die länder und
brandenburg das hier stabilität brauchen
wir brauchen stabile politische
verhältnisse umgehen die vorhin
diskutierten herausforderungen
anzunehmen um sich möglichst schnell
umzusetzen das umzusetzen was die
wählerinnen und wähler erwarten und wir
haben vor allen dingen mit dieser
stabilität wahlkampf gemacht wir haben
auch mit vertrauen und vernunft
wahlkampf gemacht und ich glaube das hat
sich am ende ausgezahlt und dass man
gegenüber hetzern und ausgrenzung
polarisieren muss das versteht sich von
selbst wenn man in einer demokratischen
partei angehört sie sprechen von
stabilität sie sind nochmal davon
gekommen in brandenburg wird das den
druck auf die spd nehmen und dazu führen
dass die spd ist auf bundesebene
leichter findet in der regierung und in
der großen koalition zu bleiben statt
jetzt frustriert die türen zuzuschlagen
und zu gehen ich glaube dass die spd in
der großen koalition wichtige dinge für
das land umgesetzt hat und was die
wählerinnen und wähler wollen ist dass
sich dinge im land bewegen dass sie in
die richtige richtung gehen und wenn ich
da an die diskussion jetzt eine
grundrente denke wenn ich eine struktur
steigungs gesetz denke wenn ich an das
gute kita gesetz denke ich könnte noch
die aufzählung hat die spd wirklich
richtig gute sachen auf den weg gebracht
und diese ständige diskussion goya oder
gruppen ein die schadet vor allem ein
und das ist die spd wir sollten uns auf
die inhalte konzentrieren auf das was
die menschen zu erwarten und eine
stabile bundesregierung wird auch hier
in hamburg von den menschen erwartet
herbert gedanke und einen schönen abend
ihnen auch dankeschön auch dieses
gespräch haben wir vor einer stunde
geführt die termine wollten es so aber
alles was jetzt in diesem heute-journal
doch läuft ist gott sei dank live vor
allen dingen natürlich wie immer
matthias die ministerpräsidenten von spd
brandenburg und cdu sachsen bleiben also
sie haben ihr amt behalten aber die wahl
haben sie bei diesen werten nun
wahrhaftig nicht gewonnen
die einzige partei mit dem man heute als
große gewinner bezeichnen kann ist die
afd
woher kommt dieser erfolg ja in der tat
klaus die afg hat in beiden
bundesländern fast
spektakulär dazugewonnen und man muss ja
schon mal fragen woher kommen denn die
wähler wählerinnen und wähler der afd
wen haben die vor fünf jahren gewählt
und da schauen wir mal auf die nächste
grafik die spd elf prozent die cdu haben
15 prozent vor fünf jahren gewählt und
jetzt afd
von der linken 7 prozent die afg selbst
38 prozent und für nichtwähler 24
prozent hier drüben sehen wir die
absoluten zahlen als schätzwerte und da
sehen wir dass 45.000 ex cdu wähler zum
beispiel diesmal fdp gewählt haben
70.000 nicht fehler das ist ein hinweis
interessant auch dass gerade was die
altersgruppen betrifft in den mittleren
gruppen also zwischen 30 und 60 die afg
sehr sehr stark ist und auch nochmal
überproportional dazu gewonnen hat und
noch eins ist interessant das schauen
wir uns als nächstes an
wer hat die afg gewählt 30 prozent
männer plus 15 prozentpunkte nur in
anführungszeichen 19 prozent frauen auch
da ein zuwachs von 9 prozentpunkten rest
geistes kind ist diese partei wir hören
ja immer wieder von vertretern auch an
diesem wahlsonntag wir sind nicht
extremistisch wir sind nicht
populistisch wie sehen das die befragten
die wählerinnen und wähler in sachsen
und in brandenburg das sehen wir auf der
nächsten grafik ist rechtsextremes
gedankengut in der afg weit verbreitet
haben wir gefragt zwei drittel sagen in
brandenburg 63 prozent fast genauso
viele in sachsen das ist ein sehr
eindeutiges bild und das erklärt dann
sicher auch die polarisierung die diese
partei auslöst wie wird die afd bewertet
wir haben da eine skala von +5 das ist
sehr positiv bis -5 das ist sehr negativ
bei allen wird die afg mit minus 2,3
bewerteten jetzt schauen wir aber mal
auf die einzelnen anhängergruppen minus
4,1 spd-anhänger minus 3,6 cdu minus 4,3
linke minus 4,6 grüne also so negativ
wie man eine partei nur bewerten kann
und nur die afg anhänger selbst geben
dieser partei eine positive werte und
das erklärt natürlich auch dass sie so
ein anti block in den parlamenten ist
weil niemand mit ihnen regieren will
dankeschön matthias und jetzt berichten
anne hertz lieb und andreas weise
über den wahlabend bei den gewinnern
dieses abends und das ist nun mal die
afd
danach sprechen wir mit ihrem
spitzenkandidaten in brandenburg sie
haben allen grund zu jubeln
die sächsische fdp mit rekordergebnis
die umfragen noch übertroffen
zweitstärkste kraft im freistaat 3,7
jetzt zur hochzuschnellen aber wir haben
das wie gesagt schon auf der straße
gespürt im wahlkampf die bürger die er
haben uns das einfach auch sehr über
gebraucht damit rechtspopulistisch im
wahlprogramm erfolgreich auf stimmenfang
als protestpartei des ostens hat sie die
linke wohl abgelöst und die
wahlbeteiligung scheint ja noch mal
zur europa und zur kommunalwahl
eingestiegen zu sein und das denke ich
dass wird der wir konnten halt die
nichtwähler dann mobilisieren thilo
alexe beobachtet die afg für die
sächsische zeitung auch wenn sie erst
sechs jahre alt ist die partei hat es
geschafft in sachsen wurzeln zu schlagen
hier konnten sich strukturen bilden hier
haben sich als erstes auch recht
mitglieder starke ortsverbände gegründet
die afg hat in sachsen das ist ebenfalls
ein erfolg eine relativ gut
strukturierte parteibasis bleibt nun die
frage ob die afg überhaupt alle sitze im
sächsischen landtag besetzen kann
derzeit darf sie nur 30 aufgrund von
verfahrensfehlern bei der nominierung
der listenkandidaten und die zahl der
direktmandate ist noch offen
doch darüber will man ab morgen streiten
am abend ging es erstmal auf einen app
dampfer zum feiern mit bundesprominenz
und ohne presse
super ergebnis super glücklich 24
weshalb nicht laufen können
hochstimmung bei der wahlparty der afg
im brandenburgischen werder das ergebnis
der landtagswahl über den erwartungen
viele wie diese nachwuchspolitiker der
jungen alternative sehen die afg als
neue volkspartei sind die stärkste kraft
geworden
aber wir haben heute trotzdem geschichte
geschrieben und das werden die bürger in
den kommenden fünf jahren merken woran
ein aktiver politik ja wir werden die
etablierten parteien schwerer machen
ein paar meter weiter eine demonstration
von anwohnern gegen die afd
repräsentativen eindruck haben sie von
mir in unserem land konzerte mit füßen
treten aber wichtig ist dass jahr den
ich regierungsfähig sein kann
hoffentlich für die afg
nachwuchspolitiker ist das nur eine
frage der zeit
wir haben wir noch ein paar jahre zeit
um dann werden wir auch im westen noch
bessere ergebnisse bekommen die nächsten
fünf jahre zumindest ist die afg in
brandenburg zweitstärkste kraft
und damit ist dieser abend eindeutig ein
erfolg für den afc spitzenkandidaten und
vorsitzenden in brandenburg andreas
kalbitz guten abend nach potsdam in den
landtag günter klinger sie haben
gewonnen sie haben angekündigt dass sie
die wende vollenden wollen das war einer
ihrer slogans wie werden sie das jetzt
machen
nach dem momentanen konstellation werden
wir ganz klar eine harte
oppositionsarbeit machen wir haben den
nerv vieler menschen getroffen man muss
ja grundsätzlich immer klarstellen die
afg ist nicht die ursache für irgendwas
kfd ist die wirkung auf das versagen der
anderen hätten die ihren job richtig
gemacht caps uns gar nicht es ist der
katzenjammer groß
es geht darum dass viele dinge auch im
befinden der menschen im osten noch
nicht vollendet sind wir reden konkret
über die rentenangleichung ost west dass
eines der beispiele wären aber auch über
die voraussetzung infrastrukturell um
eine wirtschaftliche grundlage zu
schaffen dass das lohn- und
gehaltsniveau angeglichen wird das sind
alles dinge die sind auf der strecke
geblieben auch unter 30 jahre
spd mit regierung wäre etwas so groß ist
wie wände vollenden will der muss am
ende ja auch regierungsverantwortung
wollen sonst kann das nichts werden wäre
es dafür nicht zweckmäßig wenn die afg
spitzen personen hätte die sich nicht
alle nase lang mit irgendwelchen
scheibchenweisen enthüllungen aus einer
sagen wer flott phase mit neonazis und
rechtsextreme erklären müssen ich weiß
natürlich genau auf was sie an spielen
das ist jetzt sehr dezent anonym
gehalten
ich denke darum geht's nicht ich denke
die menschen haben sehr genau
durchblickt das kurz vor der wahl wenn
dann so eine so negative campaigning
kommt und da versucht wird negativ zu
setzen dass das viele menschen eben
nicht erreicht haben wir auch an den
zahlen gesehen die spd hat sich dann
auch ministerpräsident hat sich ja
völlig von themen gelöst das ging nur
noch um ein feindbild wahlkampf gegen
die afd
ich denke dass viele menschen nicht
lieber halbe zumindest drei mit mit
verlaub aber wenn jemand andere record
ist also dokumentiert sagt dass er die
deutschland hasserin margot käßmann
verurteilt weil sie bereit ist das
deutsche volk aufzulösen und das ist
alles mit klaren zitaten belegt dann ist
diese denke doch vielen menschen fremd
und macht es für parteien wie die spd
oder die cdu und andere sagen sie immer
traditionsparteien sehr schwierig mit
einem andreas kalbitz jemals
zusammenzuarbeiten
sie haben völlig recht dass das sehr
pointierte aussagen sind man kann eine
andere meinung haben das ist keine frage
meiner meinung muss auch nicht jedem
gefallen mir gefallen gefällt ja auch
vieles nicht was ich mir da anhören muss
von links und von den grünen aber das
gehört nun mal zur demokratie es hat nur
mit rechtsextremismus nichts zu tun und
ich bin zuversichtlich dass ich wenn wir
uns die entwicklung in der union
anschauen auch wie die union intern
erodiert thema werte union da bewegt
sich hier im land auch auf kommunaler
ebene bereits einiges ich denke der ton
der union wird sich mittel und
langfristig ändern weil die union ja
auch hier in brandenburg jetzt an den
ergebnisse festgestellt hat dieser kurs
den sie da weiter geht der ist nicht
erfolgreich da führt nicht in die
regierung
antworten vielleicht in der
konstellation wo man versprechen brechen
muss wenn man sagt wir machen jetzt doch
mit der spd eine regierung insofern bin
ich zuversichtlich wir haben hier auch
im sache orientierten themen wahlkampf
gemacht und kein protestwahl kommt wenn
sich unser programm anschauen und es ist
bei vielen menschen angekommen
alexander gauland wird nächstes jahr 80
sie sind eben nachgefolgt wenn ihre
jetzige position in brandenburg wären
sie nach dem erfolg heute unter
umständen auch der geeignete nachfolger
auf bundesebene
ich habe dazu ganz klar stellung bezogen
das sehe ich im moment nicht ich sehe
ganz klar vor dem fernseher in bar
das ist völlig richtig ich sehe ich habe
ganz klar ausgeschlossen für den
bundesparteitag im november dass ich als
bundesvorsitzender kandidieren werde
ich glaube es braucht im moment in
kandidaten der auch mit blick auf den
westen es ist sehr wichtig dass wir
jetzt den westen stärken
nach den austrian kandidaten der als
integrativer vielleicht nicht so klar
verortet wahrgenommen wird
innerparteilich und ich glaube wir haben
da eine reihe von kandidaten dieser gut
in frage kommt ich werde mich mit voller
kraft der aufgabe im landtag hier widmen
als fraktionsvorsitzender und ich bin ja
auch mitglied des bundesvorstandes das
möchte ich auch bleiben aber als
bundesvorsitzender stehe ich zur zeit
nicht zur verfügung
danke herr carl bildt einen guten abend
bringen vielen dank und bringen wir
damit unsere berichterstattung auf die
ebene der hauptstadt und der
bundespolitik die traditionsparteien
haben heute mit großer anspannung auf
diesen abend geblickt winnie heescher
über die reaktion
alexander gauland kommt spät zwar auf
die wahlparty und her kommt als
beschwörer in einem bekannten vokabular
in einer altbekannten tonlage der kampf
ist nicht zu ende
der kampf geht heute erst los aber wir
sind sehr viel stärker geworden uns
kriegt man aus der deutschen politik
nicht mehr weg da bleibt mir so gut wie
sie in den umfragen da standen ist es am
ende auch für die gründe nicht
ausgegangen und doch ohne sieg eine
koalitionsbildung es sei denn man nehme
afd
wir haben die aussicht auf zwei
regierungsbeteiligungen der abend ist
noch lang und es wird extrem knapp
werden
ich will aber vor allem mit blick auf
die cdu und sachsen und die cdu in
sachsen sagen es liegt jetzt an ihnen
klar dafür zu sorgen dass es keine
regierung oder tolle regung durch den
rechtspopulismus und die afg geht
ansonsten weit und breit große
nüchternheit im willy brandt haus stehen
einige journalisten in der lehre das
kommissarische parteichef trio hat nicht
viel zu sagen über sachsen schon gar
nicht und brandenburg gerade mal gut
gegangen und die gesamte brandenburger
spd haben haltung bewiesen
gleichzeitig ist es schmerzlich verluste
eingefahren zu haben aber angesichts der
schwierigen ausgangslage ist das ein
erfolg über fehler der cdu parteichefin
ist in den vergangenen wochen manches
geschrieben worden
aus berlin war man den wahlkämpfern
keine große hilfe
klingt auch ein bisschen bei mir
der sekretär durch dieses ergebnis in
sachsen ist auch ein ganz persönlicher
erfolg von michael kretschmer das hat er
dadurch geschafft weil er redlich die
interessen des freistaates sachsen in
den mittelpunkt seiner politik gestellt
hat schaut man linken und liberalen ins
gesicht sieht man hier wie dort nur
enttäuschung und hier wie dort hat man
diese in gründung
ich war optimistisch auch durch die gut
besuchten veranstaltungen die gute
stimmung im land aber die zahlen heute
zeigen sehr viele werden aus taktischen
gründen trotz sympathie für die fdp
anders gewählt haben wir sind auch
hinter dem geblieben was die letzten
umfrageergebnisse ausgesagt haben
das hat sicher damit zu tun dass es zum
schluss eine polarisierung gab und viele
menschen nicht wollten dass die afg
stärkste partei wird was das alles macht
mit berlin luft anhalten bis zur wahl in
thüringen und an viele personaldebatten
und natürlich bleibt die große frage
hält sie oder hält sie nicht olaf scholz
ist vizekanzler und finanzminister der
bundesrepublik und inzwischen auch
kandidat für den spd-vorsitz guten abend
herr scholz ihre partei braucht kraft
und zuversicht was sagen sie da heute
abend angesichts der doch ziemlich
miserablen ergebnisse drücken sind
natürlich die wahlergebnisse afd
und es wird in den nächsten jahren
darauf ankommen dass die wieder
schlechter werden und gleichzeitig ist
es so dass wir auch an stimmen verloren
haben aber sehr wohl wahrgenommen haben
dass es möglich war durch einen ganz
engagierten einsatz ein besseres
ergebnis in brandenburg zu erzielen als
das lange vorhergesagt wurde
das ist die etwas gemischte lage nach
dem wahltag man sieht auch an der bilanz
dass weder die cdu noch die spd und über
die sprechen wir jetzt besser einen
wirklichen ein wirkliches rezept gegen
den höhenflug der afg vor allem im osten
gefunden hat wir müssen gegen halten
weil wir gesehen haben gibt es sehr
viele die dort auch sehr rechte und
extreme positionen vertreten und was
herr kalbitz da zum beispiel gemacht hat
auf einer demo demo von
hat sich in athen dass es keine sache
die man einfach klein halten kann und
über die man hinweggehen kann
insofern muss das benannt werden aber es
geht auch darum die fragen zu lösen und
die probleme zu lösen die den
bürgerinnen bürgern unseres landes wie
auch viele andere länder und europa auf
den nägeln brennen wie wird das mit der
zukunft wie kann man die vielen
veränderungen den strukturwandel so
bewältigen dass niemand alleine bleibt
solidarität dass es unsere antwort auf
solche herausforderung und dann finden
wir sehr ernst auch lange und sehr
intensiv wahlkampf gemacht mit den heute
offensichtlich gewordenen ergebnissen
das kann sie jedoch nicht befriedigen
und ein weiter so ist dann doch nicht
unbedingt die richtige antwort weiter so
ist nie die richtige antwort solidarität
ist aber auf alle fälle auch in der
zukunft ein wichtiges prinzip für das
zusammenleben in unserem land und wir
müssen verhindern dass nationalismus und
ressentiments als antwort empfunden
werden ich glaube es wird jetzt
demnächst darauf ankommen sehr gute
ergebnisse zu erzielen
bei den fragen die viele auf der
tagesordnung finden und wo wir große
fortschritte machen müssen ein thema hat
in den letzten wochen eine große rolle
gespielt das ist zum beispiel wie können
wir im bereich der sozialen sicherheit
mit einer grundrente für bessere renten
bei denjenigen sorgen die sehr wenig
verdient haben ihrem leben trotz harter
arbeit oder zum beispiel das große
menschheitsthema des klimawandels wenn
wir dort gute ergebnisse erzielen dann
wird sich das auch auszahlen aber noch
mal dass ressentiments ist keine antwort
und das werden wir auch weiter klar
sagen müssen
nehmen wir mal die grundrente da stehen
ihnen ja jetzt schwierige verhandlungen
mit ihrem koalitionspartner bevor die
spd will die grundrechte ohne
bedürftigkeitsprüfung die cdu besteht
auf der bedürftigkeitsprüfung wäre das
nicht ein guter punkt wo die spd dann
sagt aus prinzip
und weil es uns und die wertschätzung
aller rentner geht auch der gut
verdienen niemand muss irgendetwas
vorlegen man kriegt sie einfach mit mit
dieser position die koalition zu
verlassen und dann zu sagen so gerade
laufen wir sozialdemokraten wir werden
gerade in dieser frage laufen das tun
wir ja das haben sie gemerkt ich laufen
all die diskussion verfolgt die wir zu
diesem thema führen
meine these ist es kann sehr wohl
möglich sein dass wir ein sehr gutes
ergebnis erzielen
für uns ist eines ganz klar als der
bundesarbeitsminister gesagt hat er
schlägt vor eine grundrente eine
rente den respekt vor der
arbeitsleistung vieler bürgerinnen und
bürger widerspiegelt einzuführen haben
sich wahrscheinlich 23 millionen bürgern
und bürger direkt gemeint gefühlt wir
werden natürlich nicht mit einem
ergebnis nach hause gehen wo es dann mit
100 oder 200 tausend geht und deshalb
sind die gespräche noch sehr hart aber
wir sind gewillt sie zu einem
ordentlichen ergebnis zu führen und zwar
in dem sinne der bürgerinnen und bürger
unseres landes
die gespräche werden hart und damit
gegenstand unserer berichterstattung
dankeschön heute abend herr schon
genannt und für den partner in der
großen koalition begrüße ich jetzt den
aachen armin laschet ministerpräsident
von nordrhein-westfalen und
stellvertretender vorsitzender der cdu
genannter lasche genannter kleber die
zeitverzögerung zwischen und zweitens
wieder schrecklich und macht ein
gespräch schwierig versuchen wir es
trotzdem
sie hatten die schlechtesten ergebnisse
in 30 jahren vereint der bundesrepublik
in diesen beiden bundesländern was muss
ihre partei heute aus dem ergebnis
lernen also in der tat dass es richtig
die schlechtesten ergebnisse seit vielen
vielen jahren aber dennoch glaube ich
muss man differenzieren was können wir
als bundespartei tun und was kann man in
den neuen bundesländer tun in den neuen
bundesländern war der kurs von michael
kretschmer richtig klare knallharte
abgrenzung gegen die afd
und das hat ihm am ende auch die stimmen
vieler unentschlossener noch gebracht
und zweitens die methode kretzschmar zu
hören überall präsent sein
in die kleinsten veranstaltungen gehen
und all diese wut die es ja auch bei den
wählern gibt versuchen aufzufangen und
antworten zu geben
in westen sieht das in vielem anders aus
bei uns hier in nordrhein westfalen
liegt die fdp bei sieben prozent
hier ist es glaube ich wichtig die dinge
die jetzt anstehen die kompliziert
werden der praxis steht vor der tür der
kohleausstieg steht vor der tür
die europäische union steht in
schwierigen zeiten
hier den zusammenhalt zu fördern das
wird auch in der lausitz jetzt das thema
werden wie gelingt es aus einer
energieform mit arbeitsplatzverlust
auszusteigen und trotzdem neue
industrielle produktion hin zu bringen
das geht nur mit maß und mitte gegen
diese radikalität gegen diese aggression
mit kluge antworten und vor allem mit
ergebnissen und die muss jetzt auch die
bundesregierung in den nächsten wochen
liefern das wird hart hat olaf scholz
gerade gesagt weil die positionen doch
in den dingen die nun aufgeschoben
worden sind in denen man sich noch nicht
hat einigen können
doch ziemlich schwierig wird ist es da
nicht so dass diese große koalition in
wirklichkeit hauptsächlich
zusammengehalten wird von der
gemeinsamen angst vor neuwahlen jetzt
denn sie sind ja beide relativ schlecht
dafür aufgestellte morgen glück also ich
glaube sie wird zusammengehalten durch
durch ein bei allen ausgeprägtes
verantwortungsbewusstsein in dieser lage
in der sich unser land im moment
befindet wo wichtige entscheidungen
anstehen kann man doch nicht
leichtfertig eine koalition auflösen und
in neuwahlen hineingehen man überzeugt
die zweifler am besten indem man gute
ergebnisse liefern
und die sind in den nächsten wochen zur
klimapolitik zum kohleausstieg zur
schaffung neuer arbeitsplätze
betroffenen regionen verräterin dieser
sage dass sie das jetzt hinkriegen weil
die zahlen auch von heute in eine
gewisse opfer bereitschaft bei
kompromissen abverlangen sie müssen sind
kriegen sie müssen dieser rentenfrage
lösen sie müssen den kohleausstieg lösen
dafür gibt es ja eben eine große
koalition
die heißt große weil sie große aufgaben
bewältigen muss und die ergebnisse
müssen uns heute wirklich wach rütteln
bei der europawahl und bei der
bundestagswahl war die fdp noch auf
platz eins in sachsen das ist heute
nicht mehr der fall aber trotzdem
erschüttern mich 27 prozent stimmen
charlotte knobloch die frühere
vorsitzende des zentralrats der juden
hat mit entsetzen auf dieses ergebnis
von rechtsextremen rechtsradikalen
parteien reagiert heute ist der erste
september ein tag wo man an die folgen
von nationalismus auch erinnert hat und
das hatten wir noch kein wunsch ein
wenig erreicht muss aber klarer kante
ich muss sie unterbrechen damit wir
unsere bürger stört und was erst noch
schaffen
gleich ich bitte um nachsicht und danke
für das gespräch zu den ergebnissen und
den entwicklungen dieses spannenden
abends nun der kommentar von peter
fahren
30 jahre nach dem mauerfall haben
erschreckend viele aus deutsche welle
eine rechtspopulistische partei gewählt
aus protest weil sie mit dem deutschland
von heute nicht zufrieden sind oder ganz
einfach weil sie nationalistisch denken
doch der erfolg in sachsen und
brandenburg hat für die afg einen preis
er stärkt den extremen flügel
die partei steht jetzt vor
radikalisierung und richtungsstreit ihre
machtpolitischen ziele erreicht die afg
heute nicht nicht stärkste kraft zur
regierungsbildung wird sie nicht
gebraucht dass ihre spitzenkandidaten im
fernsehen bieder daher reden und dem
netz um so schlimmer hetzen dass sie
unverschämt die losungen der friedlichen
revolution klauen hat mehrheit und mitte
der wählerschaft nicht überzeugt cdu und
spd haben mit taktischen fehlern auf den
letzten metern gewonnen
michael kretschmer hat die sachsens cdu
wählbar gemacht im dauer gespräch mit
dem wlan
er holte sein direktmandat im umkämpften
görlitz sein aufwärtstrend stabilisierte
sich jegliche er sich von der afg
abgrenzte in brandenburg konnte die spd
mit dem klassen aber bodenständigen
dietmar woidke das schlimmste verhindern
ein wichtiges signal für die total
verunsicherte sozialdemokratie
und die große koalition im bund der
heute einschließlich der
cdu-vorsitzenden kramp karrenbauer ein
wenig stabilität eingehaucht wurde
die grünen werden stärker können
wahrscheinlich mitregieren
aber ihre wahlergebnisse sind wieder
einmal schwächer als die umfragen die
linke könnte ihre regierungsbeteiligung
in ihrem kern land brandenburg noch
verlieren und damit den status der ost
partei endgültig die afd welle ist nicht
gebrochen
die anliegen ihrer wälder müssen ernst
genommen werden
30 jahre einheit und das land ist noch
lange nicht einig aber die starke
wahlbeteiligung heute zeigt die
demokratie lebt auch im osten und die
botschaft an die afg ist klar es gibt
machbare stabile mehrheiten jenseits der
populisten die einschätzung von
chefredakteur peter frey nachrichten nun
von gundula gause
im jemen sind bei luftangriffen
mindestens 65 menschen getötet und
dutzende verletzt worden
seit 2015 sind dem krieg in dem
bitterarmen land am golf von aden laut
un mehr als zehntausend menschen zum
opfer gefallen
die von saudi arabien geführte
militärkoalition attackierte ein gebäude
das sie als waffenlager der houthi
rebellen bezeichnete nach deren angaben
aber wurde ein gefängnis getroffen in
dem kämpfer der regierungstruppen
festgehalten worden sein
hongkong hat an diesem wochenende
schwere ausschreitungen erlebt nach
heftigen zusammenstößen zwischen polizei
und demonstranten störten heute wieder
tausende hongkonger den betrieb am
internationalen flughafen
die proteste an diesem 13
demonstrations- wochenende in folge
richten sich gegen den zunehmenden
einfluss der kommunistischen führung
chinas und gegen polizeigewalt
erneut hat in den usa ein bewaffneter
mann offenbar wahllos um sich geschossen
und sieben menschen getötet
der angriff begann bei einer
verkehrskontrolle nach odessa im us
bundesstaat texas
plötzlich schoss der mann auf einen
polizisten raste davon und schoss
peter in odessa um sich die polizei
streckte ihn nieder und ermittelt wegen
des motivs der sich den usa nähern der
wirbelsturm dorian hat die höchste
haarigen stufe erreicht er zieht in
diesen stunden auf die bahamas zu und
könnte dort mit meter hohen wellen
windgeschwindigkeiten von um die 300
stundenkilometern und starken
regenfällen schäden anrichten
nach berechnungen des us hurrikan
warnzentrum skandalen auch die
bundesstaaten north und south carolina
oder die ostküste floridas treffen
vor 80 jahren begann am frühen morgen
dieses tages am ersten september 1939
der krieg der später zweiter weltkrieg
genannt wurde kriegsausbruch hieß das
lange eine irreführende formulierung
vulkane brechen aus dieser krieg war
kein unabwendbares naturereignis sondern
eine bis ins detail geplante
angriffskrieg mit dem ziel zu rauben und
zu töten
er begann mit einer lüge und mit einem
verbrechen die hochgerüstete deutsche
luftwaffe löschte eine wehrlose
polnische kleinstadt aus juni parallel
zum angriff deutscher kriegsschiffe auf
der westerplatte bei danzig
bundespräsident walter steinmeier hat
heute genau dort in berlin noch vor
morgengrauen in einer klarheit
gesprochen
die polen lange vermisst hatten
es ist ein tag voller symbolik schon der
zeitpunkt ist eine starke geste früher
morgen so wie damals in wien als der
krieg begann erstmals gedenkt ein
deutscher bundespräsident in der
kleinstadt der opfer das tragische
schicksal wir nun zwar lange vergessen
in den geschichtsbüchern in deutschland
kaum bekannt
man hat mit deutschland zu tun und
deutscher schuld wenn man als deutscher
geboren ist
wer sich auf deutsche geschichte berufen
will der muss auch diesen satz von
thomas mann ertragen
ich verneige mich vor den opfern des
überfalls auf jeden ich verneige mich
vor den polnischen opfern der deutschen
gewaltherrschaft und ich bitte um
vergebung
es sind seine wichtigsten worte des
tages für polen das bitten um vergebung
dann auch auf polnisch
[Applaus]
sie stellen sich der wahrheit herr
bundespräsident
es ist eine schwierige wahrheit für die
deutschen für deutschland aber niemals
hat deutschland diese wahrheit verneint
der erste september 39
morgens um 44 greifen sturz kampfbomber
die noch schlafende stadt an töten 1200
das erste deutsche kriegsverbrechen in
wien gibt es keine polnischen soldaten
nur zivile dieses dröhnen mit einem
befehl und das pfeifen
ich weiß nicht genau wie ich es
beschreiben soll
es war so erschreckend joseph champion
war damals sieben jahre alt er hat
überlebt durch einen zufall weil seine
familie gerade aus einem haus ausgezogen
war das den bomben zum opfer fiel
das waren meine nachbarn meine freunde
die da gestorben sind und uns hätte
dasselbe schicksal ereilt wenn wir nicht
einen einzigen monat zuvor
gerade umgezogen werden
er ist einer der überlebenden der heute
den deutschen bundespräsidenten trifft
in warschau das zentrale gedenken
vertreter der eu und nato staaten hat
polen eingeladen
russland nicht wegen des streits um die
krim auch hier zeit sollen steinmeier
bittet erneut um vergebung
wir vergessen die wunden nicht die
deutsche polen zugefügt haben die
botschaft des tages ein nie wieder
und so läuten sie beide die glocke zum
gedächtnis und zur mahnung die so
verletzte polnische seele braucht
gedenken wie diese 80 jahre nach dem
ausbruch des zweiten weltkrieges unsere
polen korrespondent in natalie steger
die gerade diesen bericht gemacht hat
hat die wichtigsten momente der
gedenkveranstaltungen von heute auch in
einem ausführlichen film zusammengefasst
zu sehen heute nacht um 950 oder schon
jetzt und jederzeit in der mediathek
noch einmal nachrichten.de auch
historische tage und jahrestage
enthalten aktuellen krönender abschluss
der ruder-wm im österreichischen linz
zweimal gold für die deutschen ruderer
erst gewann das aushängeschild des
deutschen ruderverbandes der
deutschland-achter gold vor den
niederlanden und den briten
es ist der dritte titel in serie und das
ticket für die olympischen spiele
nächstes jahr
und dann wollte auch einer
senkrechtstarter oliver zeidler gold dem
ex schwimmer gelang das erste deutsche
einer gold seit 17 jahren in der fußball
bundesliga hat eintracht frankfurt am
abend fortuna düsseldorf 2 zu 1 besiegt
und werder bremen gewann am nachmittag
gegen den fc augsburg 3 zu 2
das wetter bringt in der neuen woche
angenehmere temperaturen sowie immer mal
wieder schauer so regnet es morgen im
südosten kräftig an den alpen anhaltend
zum teil mit gewittern
das wird es auch in nordseenähe sonst
freundlich bei 13 bis 23 grad
am dienstag scheint fast überall die
sonne am mittwoch regnet es im norden
bevor es dann wieder windiger und kühler
wird 14 bis 21 grad
man muss kein prophet zu sein um zu
wissen der ausgang der landtagswahlen
heute wird den politischen betrieb in
berlin mindestens für die nächsten tage
beherrschen ist ja kirsch mit einem
kurzen blick auf absehbare ereignisse
der kommenden woche ansonsten
[Musik]
spannung in london am dienstag kommt das
britische parlament nach der sommerpause
erstmals wieder zusammen
ministerpräsident chancen für die
abgeordneten bald danach wieder in eine
zwangspause schicken um den rexit ende
oktober zu ermöglichen
die empörung ist groß von einem putsch
die rede
die sitzung wird sicher turbulent der
außenminister im kongo heiko maas reist
am mittwoch nach afrika hier im osten
des kongo wütet seit monaten eine ebola
epidemie
mehr als 2000 menschen sind schon
gestorben dazu kommt die politische
unsicherheit in dem riesigen start im
zentrum afrikas kann deutsche
außenpolitik hier stabilisierend wirken
100 jahre waldorfschule am samstag wird
in stuttgart gefeiert
hier wird seit 1919 unterrichtet auf der
grundlage der anthroposophie lernen ohne
angst das war revolutionär
ministerpräsident kretschmann will auch
gratulieren die waldorfpädagogik ist ein
echter exportschlager heute gibt es über
1000 waldorfschulen in mehr als 80
ländern der erde
wir wünschen ihnen eine gute woche
marietta slomka heinz wolf erwarten sie
jeden tag abends hier
bis bald genannt
[Musik]